prob abilities if it's not immediately clear on the surface why that's interesting or important that's okay but we do use this
fact very frequently when we're reasoning about density matrices and in fact expressing a given density Matrix
in this way is often the very first thing that we do when we want to understand it
better here's an example recall the density Matrix that we came up with earlier where we randomly chose between
the zero State and in the plus State each with probability 1/2 which as we calculated has a density Matrix that
looks like this the zero State and the plus state are not orthogonal so this isn't a
spectral decomposition but if we compute one which we can do with a computer or by hand in a case like this then what we
get is this expression of our density Matrix where the IG values are these numbers that keep on showing up and
where the corresponding IG vectors can be chosen as is shown down here on the screen and again we've seen these vectors before for instance in the
context of the chsh game in Lesson Four so that's interesting according to
the original expression this state is what we get by uniformally choosing between two states the zero State and
the plus state but in fact we get exactly the same density matrix by randomly choosing between two pure
States but we're very very heavily biasing towards one of them about 85% for the first one and only about 15% for
the second one so in some sense there's actually rather less Randomness inherent to the state than it originally might have
seemed there's a very nice geometric way of thinking about and visualizing Quantum states of a single Cubit known
as the block sphere it only works for single cubits for systems having three
or more classical States including two or more cubits together it doesn't work anymore so it is quite limited but
nevertheless it's it's a great way to think about the states of a single Cubit it could have been introduced way
back in lesson one of the series on single systems but it's not really essential to understanding how Quantum information works and it also has a
really nice connection with density matrices so it fits naturally into this lesson and in fact I'm going to explain
it in a somewhat different way than it's perhaps most typically explained by using density matrices to effectively
derive it so if you're already familiar with the block sphere this explanation may be a little bit different from the
way you first learned about it but in the end it should of course be equivalent we'll start by thinking about
the possible pure states of a cubit first as represented by Quantum State
vectors up to a global phase every Cubit Quantum State Vector can be expressed as
is shown here on the screen to be precise we have two real numbers Theta and fi and we'll think
about these two numbers as being angles expressed in radians the first number Theta is between 0 and Pi or equivalently it's an
angle between 0 and 180° and the second number five is between 0 and 2 pi including 0 but not 2
pi so that's any angle between 0 and 360° the Zero Entry of our Vector is
cosine of theta / 2 so that's a real number between 0 and 1 and in particular it's necessarily non- negative
and the one entry of our Vector is e to the I * 5 * the S of th / 2 and that can
be any complex number on or inside the complex unit circle this is always a unit vector or
in other words it's a valid Quantum State vector and for any given cubic Quantum State Vector we can always find
a vector of this form that's equivalent to that Vector up to a global phase in particular we can always
multiply the given vector by a global phase to make the Zero Entry a non- negative real number choose whatever
Theta Works to give us that entry and then pick five to match the one entry the magnitude of the one entry will
always necessarily agree with the sign of theta over two by the assumption that we started with a unit
Vector now it isn't quite the case that Theta and F are uniquely determined by whatever Quantum State Vector we started
with but it's almost the case there's always going to be a unique value of theta between zero and Pi that works
and usually there's a unique value of five that works but in two special cases that's not true in particular if we started with a
standard basis State then Theta will be either zero or pi and in both cases it doesn't actually matter what f is it's
completely irrelevant when Theta is zero the cosine of theta / 2 is 1 and the S of theta / 2
is z so we're multiplying e to the I * F to zero so it doesn't make any difference what f is
and if Theta is pi then this time the cosine is zero and the S is one so we have e to the I * 5 * kat1 but those
vectors are all equivalent up to a global phase so again it doesn't matter what f is however if Theta lies properly
between Z and Pi then there's always going to be a unique value of F that works and by the way this possible
degeneracy in the value of f for the two special cases will make perfect sense when we see the geometric picture in
just a little bit now let's compute the density Matrix associated with a state Vector of the form that we just
identified so this is going to be a pure state of a cubit to do this we multiply the vector
to its conjugate transpose as usual and on the screen is an expression of the Matrix that we get by Computing the
conjugate transpose and doing the multiplication now just like every 2x2
matrix there's a unique way to obtain this matx matrix by taking a linear combination of the poly matrices
including the identity Matrix in particular we can get this matrix by choosing the coefficients of
the poly matrices as is shown here on the screen we're putting a two in the denominator because that's going to make
everything work out nicely nothing forces us to do this but we can and it's going to be helpful to do that but aside
from this cosmetic Choice there is no Freedom here this is the only way to get this matrix by taking a linear combination of poly matrices that's
because the poly matrices including the identity Matrix are a basis for the vector space of all 2x2 matrices one way
to check the correctness of this expression is to make use of some basic trigonometric identities and in particular if I move out of the way for
just a moment here we have some identities that will do the trick so if you're so inclined pause the video or
take a screenshot and see if you can obtain the second expression of the density Matrix on the bottom from the first so in summary any pure state of a
cubit expressed as a density Matrix can be written as a linear combination of poly matrices like is shown on the